well Happy New Year everybody and welcome to
the first ever episode of The Jackie Redmond
show yes it's actually happening I know right
but I couldn't be more excited to kick things
off from here at the Winter Classic it truly
is one of my favorite events that the NHL does
because every location is different special and
unique in its own right which are things that
I hope this show can emulate so thank you for
joining us we've got a jam-pack premere episode
we'll chat with the golden nights and the Kraken
we'll take you behind the scenes at this beautiful
Ballpark and we might even get to hang out with
a Seattle sports legend yeah I'm jacked let's
rock Zach White Cloud I heard a rumor that you
lived somewhere where you could skate home from
the outdoor ranks or the ponds or wherever that's
true actually the the elementary school I went to
Valley View uh was about a block down from where
I grew up so I would obviously walk to school and
then our community rank was right beside the
school uh so sometimes obviously the uh the
graders didn't get in the back Lanes so I would
go right from The Ring grab my stuff and just kind
of go through the back Lane go home wow okay so
what's the over under on the amount of money your
parents had to spend on skate sharpening uh well
honestly I probably just play with doll skates I
think that's uh yeah that's I mean that was the uh
the the downside to it um yeah or Spin Zone maybe
you became better at playing on and when you were
forced to do so you're like whatever this is old
and now it seems like whenever you get a Nick in
your skate the world's the world's coming coming
to a close so um no I was I was super lucky
um being able to grow up obviously one with a
backyard rink I think that's something that I um
never fully appreciated until I got older now at
the time of this conversation the game day fits
have not yet been revealed so I'm not going to
ask you to spoil anything but I will ask you who
is The Mastermind behind what the Vegas golden
knights will be wearing tomorrow when they arrive
to the ballpark here in Seattle Elvis and Elvis
and Elvis and Elvis all in the building today uh
I'm not going to be a leak for anything so I'm not
no I'm not asking for a leak I just want I know
I don't want to give it away cuz it's it's just
Vegas right so it's uh you know it's a okay it's
an entertainment City and it's it's super cool you
know everyone it's like it's the one place in the
world where I think a lot of people just want to
go right and experience once here you are you're
an NHL Pro you're a Stanley Cup champion and you
know 10 years ago you were never sure you would
actually make it just to this point to play a game
in the National what would you go back and tell
yourself that maybe 15 16 whatever age you were
when you when you weren't making the best teams
oh man uh don't stress you know a lot of people
for whatever reason my path specifically I think a
lot of people ask you know what what was a turning
point point or why did the attitude change or why
did this happen why didn't that happen and it's
honestly because I had zero expectations and
I think when you don't have many expectations
you do things because you love it whether that's
your career that you're starting on a university
or your job that you're starting out of high
school whatever it is find something you love
and do it and but do it incredibly well right
because you love it um and hockey was that for
me I just I kept playing and playing and playing
to win with my friends to play hockey to create
you know lifelong friendships so it really was
a sort of a path of you know driven by Passion
and not necessarily I have to make it yeah and I
think I mean the the thing that I always go back
to is after my u8 season uh my last year I was
pretty much ready to go and work after or go to
university whatever it was and and that was fine
with me you know what I mean that was that's not
what I was meant to do but that's that's kind
of what my path was like laid out to be right
and that's kind of what everyone did um and then
hockey just obviously kept kept going not to get
too hippie dippy but it sounds like you were you
were very okay with going with the flow of of the
universe like you're going to make decisions for
yourself that are right for you and that you're
passionate about and that feel right but you're
just kind of like hey however this plays out ex
I'm good with it and it's the same with hockey
right you can only control so much right and
you can only control your own effort what kind
of teammate you are what kind of person you are
at the rink away from the rink how involved you
are in the community you you can control those
things yeah um what you can't control is all the
other little stuff and that's you know I think a
lot of people say it too is only focus on way you
can control and I think that's kind of what I've
done throughout my career I've controlled my
work ethic my attention to detail and you know
I've never had to tell myself go do that because
you love the game or because you do that I just
I've just gone and done it yeah um so I think
that part that work ethic was instilled in me
um you know pretty early and then I worked on it
myself cuz work ethic I think is something you
have to work on um so for me I think that's kind
of what's carried me through and and uh again the
zero expectations thing and it's I've told people
a lot it's don't get confused with not caring
that's a big difference right yeah cuz that's
where being a good teammate comes in too right
is is working hard but you know caring about the
results and what you're doing for your teammates
and and all that sort of stuff and and uh and
that's still why I play today I play because
of those guys in the room the relationships that
you know how close our team is that's that's why
you play hockey so you're coming off a s cup win
last year so I do want to know the biggest thing
you learned just how hard it is it's uh and I
think too how much it means to the whole group
that goes through it together and then how you
come out as a as a group and how close you are on
the other side of it what's the best thing about
Bruce Cassidy or your favorite thing about Bruce
Cassidy my favorite thing is his attention to
detail in the game okay um you know for for our
game specifically we have a really mature older
group right where we have had a lot of guys that
have been in leadership scenarios who know how to
control a room and how to read a room and how how
to you know when to say things when not to say
things all that sort of stuff right we've got a
group that you know we can we can push ourselves
but to have a person in a motivator like that is
is big for our group as well because you know he
leads us into the fight every night as well and
then we've got furthermore you've got like you
go go down the list of guys on our lineup that
lead you and drag you into the fight every single
night um and we've got 23 of those guys I want to
ask you um about your best Zack whitecloud Story
coming out of your Stanley Cup Celebrations like
what is the number one story that you tell I think
the funniest thing that kind of came out of the
whole for me anyways the thing that always sticks
out and the one thing for the till the day I die
will kind of resonate and it's it's very it's very
weird it might get some some weird looks okay um I
think it was like night six we were we went to we
had gone to dinner with it had Italian and um Jack
eel played Betty Davis eyes in the I know song
in the party bus Google it kids and the in the
party bus and I that was the first time I'd ever
heard it it okay you're so young yeah I know and
uh so when I heard that it was just kind of in
a moment where it was like life was like there
right it was as high as it could get and you're
just with all these special people that you just
you know spent you know how much time with in
won this amazing Trophy and uh it just like it
just it just kind of resonated everything and so
when I hear that song the memories come floting
back oh yeah and it it will still when you're
like 65 years old I'm sure and then so uh we go
to our favorite sushi spot every time so a couple
times when we go in the owner puts on Betty Davis
as when we when I walk in well people are going to
watch this now and you're going to be walking down
the street and people are just going to be like
holding up their phones and playing Betty Davis
eyes so uh I I like it it's a great song it is
a very it is a very good song that is your song
now that is Zach white Cloud's song I appreciate
the time Zach thank you so much appreciate time
appreciate Vince done welcome to the show thanks
for hanging out out I love what you've done with
the place looks looks good yeah they've done
a crazy job with all the details we were just
talking about the ship back there that everyone's
talking about and just um adding a little bit of
character um that relates to the city so it's
super cool for both teams to be a part of this
something tells me the ship is going to get
a lot of action on the gram and on Tik Tok so
you definitely should check it out it actually
is pretty cool for sure I mean this is a crazy
atmosphere you're playing outside tomorrow like
what how do you feel about this game are you pped
who's the most excited guy on the team like what's
going on you me down yeah I think just everyone is
super excited and um I'm sure both coaches are
going to kind of relay the message to just take
take in the atmosphere and um just let the game be
itself and just playing hockey and just bringing
back memories as a kid um you're going to be
outside playing so I think a lot of us can relate
to that when we were younger playing on outdoor
ranks and things like that so I think we're just
really excited to get out there and get things
rolling do you have a favorite memory as a kid
playing outside I think probably around Christmas
break and New Year is whenever we were off school
um we were always playing out back and on the
Frozen ponds and and out to our ranks and in
the backyard so um yeah it's relatable now we're
doing the same thing at the same time of the year
now it has become tradition for teams playing the
Winter Classic to Dawn some sort of outfit going
into the game I'm not going to ask you to spill
that because this is the day before the game but
I will ask you who is The Mastermind behind the
fits that the Kraken will be arriving in tomorrow
who came up with the ideas oh I actually have no
idea we had a whole outfit planned in the group
chat and it was voted on oh wow and then we were
uh kind of throwing a curveball and we're wearing
something completely different now what happened
they didn't come in or something I know I was I
was out but okay so I'm learning that Vince Dunn
is the guy that like gets the information in the
chat and shows up but doesn't necessarily plan
the thing yeah I'm pretty vocal outside of the
chat but in the chat I kind of just sit back
and and watch the party can you tell us what
the old outfits were going to be uh they were no
no they they're pretty they're pretty similar just
was trying so hard they were close to like being
pretty much the same just like different colors
they're both like very relatable to the city which
is cool so that's all I can really give all right
fair enough if you could describe Seattle Kraken
fans in one word how would you describe them loud
you can probably hear um the other Stadium beside
us rocking already so um they're passionate um I
think sometimes maybe um we get a little too
comfortable and I think they're always going
to be let you know yeah they let us know they have
been lately especially with the uh the season we
had last year last year I think the expectations
are a little higher so um that's good for us when
there's a little bit more pressure in the city but
um no they're great for us they they cheer us on
every single night even the first year when we
were struggling maybe a little bit it was it was
tough for us but they were there behind us every
single night so that's really special to have a
fan base like that every time um so hockey is a
new hobby for some people in Seattle what are your
hobbies outside of hockey like what is Vince Dunn
doing in his spare time he's not playing baseball
I don't think not playing many sport Sports and
honestly I think with us being so busy what I
like to do is just cook um really yeah I love
okay I love cooking hold the phone what is your
like special what is the number one thing you
like to cook uh well being out here probably a
lot of seafood seafood pasta love sea pasta it's
probably one of my favorite dishes so a lot of
seafood but um other than that I'm pretty guilty
of being a gamer too so just more of a chiller on
my downtime and um it's nice to be able to cook
for myself especially being on the road so much
it's it's sometimes hard to to get get the food
you want to eat um so when I'm here I just try
to just lay low and and especially playing video
games I can play with my friends back home that
maybe I don't see too much and talk to them
through there so that's always fun too what
games do you dabble in uh Call of Duty pretty much
why is it always why is it always cood it's it's
Cod or it's no one calls it like no one calls it
cood sorry Jackie that's not a thing it is for me
so maybe down the line would you ever do like
a cooking show yeah I think I actually have a
thing coming out um with team is this a scoop this
is a a stay tuned for this okay so you'll do like
different recipes every I'm going to cook with
a chef yeah that's that's one of the things I'm
trying to do in the new year so um good luck with
that I love that that's exciting yeah that should
be pretty cool you have favorite Seafood you said
you like seafood is that you have a favorite yeah
the crab I like Alaskan king crab is money yeah
the crab not the snow crab yeah no the big ones
the king craft yeah yeah 100% all right well
listen uh stay tuned for his cooking segment
coming soon to somewhere I don't know Seattle's
website probably Seattle K website it's going to
be with the Seattle the Seattle uh media group's
going to be doing it yeah okay awesome uh well
thank you so much I appreciate you next time we'll
bring a we'll bring a kitchen or something no
we'll take you to a kitchen and get you to cook
something all right thank you all right thanks
[Music] Vince I can hardly believe it but I am in
fact here with Seattle baseball Legend Ed Martinez
thank you for hanging out with us we appreciate
you coming on the show yeah thank you for having
me well we are here we are at the park you have
seen what it looks like to have a hockey rank in
here what do you what do you think of the place
it's impressive actually very impressive to see
uh the feeli here with all the hockey Pleasures
practicing so it's very cool it looks beautiful
actually I got to ask what does Edgar Martinez
know about hockey I don't know much but after
this uh after tomorrow I'm going to be more
interested said about it for sure when you
look at the game I mean there's skating there's
hitting I mean sometimes there's fighting slap
shots like what what stands out to you as as
an impressive skill about the game of hockey
you know they go uh very fast yeah and how they
can stop you know and and actually Escape at that
speed and at the same time trying to to make a
shot with the with the stick it's pretty Prive
yeah it's a lot of things all happening at
once and the fact they're doing it on these
like little tiny blades is is prettyy incredible
have you ever skated before yeah but I didn't uh
I spent more time on the eyes you need more more
reps on the skates well um I want to talk to you
about Seattle right because the hockey team has
not been here uh for very long but you have spent
a lot of time in this city what do you think
it means to sports fans in general here to now
have a hockey team because when when the team
was bought and the season tickets went up they
sold out like that yes well definitely it looked
like it's a a lot of hockey fans uh in this area
and uh we're very close to Vancouver uh so it is
it is actually really really good for the city
uh for all the fans and uh I'm excited for the
city and and for all the fans yeah we're excited
too in the hockey world that we finally have
a team um in Seattle now obviously your name
is everywhere around here I mean there's Edgars
over there the streets named after you you I mean
this is this is your town does it ever get old
being I don't know just like the best designated
hitter of all time is I like ever wear off that
novelty well I've been uh very lucky in this city
um and to have a uh long career uh very lucky
and uh but it's amazing this uh the fans here
the people in Seattle just uh took me in and it
feels like home what was your favorite Park to
hit in not in Seattle well I did really well
in New York New York was one our producer is
crying over off to the side right now Yankees
fan you did well in New York was that your why
do you think that is I don't know I it's uh hard
to tell but I saw the ball really well there and
uh I feel very comfortable playing on that field
all right so what do you do with your time now
what is what is your favorite thing to do as a
retired former legendary baseball player what
are your hobbies well I I like uh boating boating
like sailing yeah it's not sailing it's uh power
motor booat but uh I enjoyed that a lot uh and
uh just to spend time at home with the family oh
yeah well I think that's a fair answer all right
you want to go for a skate uh we'll try it all
right well listen thank you for the time enjoy
the game tomorrow we really appreciate it thank
[Music] you well you can't have a Jackie Redmond
show without five things right so here are my
five burning questions heading into 2024 number
one will Austin Matthews score 50 and 50 dude
already has 29 goals in 32 games as I stand here
today which means he only needs 21 and 18 to do
it and we're talking about a guy who opened the
season scoring hattricks in back-to-back games
right I mean he loves scoring in bunches and get
this Toronto plays their 50th game of the season
on February 10th against the Ottawa sener s yes
the same sense franchise that Matthew scored four
goals against in his NHL debut I don't know it's
feeling like a full circle moment Written in the
Stars Destiny type of thing I've said this
before and I'll say it again I don't always
believe in the Choate beliefs but I always believe
in Austin Matthews I say he does it number two can
the Oilers make the playoffs and win here's the
thing if I learned anything from Kevin Garnett
it's that anything is possible right I mean look
no further than the 2019 St Louis Blues they were
in the basement on January 3rd and they went on
to win the Stanley Cup now like the Oilers they
fired their coach in November turned it all around
and went on to you know just casually make history
but here's the thing Edmonton has been so much
better since the coaching change in fact they
have a top five points percentage since noblock
took over and they have something the blues didn't
the best player in the world in Conor McDavid just
one very small minor difference the blues did have
a goalie on a heater number three are the flyers
for real well they have important players back and
healthy Carter Hart is having a resurgent season
and the backup ain't too shabby either I mean how
many teams can say that but maybe most importantly
the Flyers are hard to play against AKA it's the
Tor special baby they clog up the neutral zone
they force turnovers and then they make you pay
they've beaten Vegas La Vancouver and Colorado
this season so you tell me real or phony number
four who will score the goal of the year I mean
scoring is up we've had amazing highlights this
season a goalie goal a couple of nice michigans
and who could forget Cool's goal over in Australia
but we're not even at the All-Star break yet I
say title's still up for grabs and finally number
five will we see Travis Kelce on the ice this
season maybe he shoots on an NHL goalie maybe
he learns how to do the Michigan with Conor Bard
I mean the possibilities are endless and I for
one just hope that maybe one of those things can
happen right here on the Jackie Redmond show but
we are all out of time for this Premiere episode
We Appreciate You tuning in like comment subscribe
do all the YouTube things that you're supposed
to do and we will see you next Friday for episode
two